un jour un autre jour un autre destin je
veux profiter de l'occasion pour prendre un
risque et faire quelque chose de très différent
limas arabe va changer la façon dont
les films musicaux sont faits pour toujours
c'est excitant c'est ce que vous vivez l'un
des grands attraits de ce nom est  est-ce
qu'il a quelque chose pour tout le monde il a
cette étendue de forces de passion et de
personnages c'est un conte épique
mais c'est très humain vous avez la
tragédie de fontein et le chagrin d'
Eponine avez-vous l'action de cette
révolution la haute  drame de jean par
Jean
il y a un niveau épique à cela il
suffit de voir ce film dans les salles c'est
nul comme comédie musicale mais ça vous donne
tellement plus
c'est le genre de film qui met
le feu à votre âme je ne peux pas vous attendre
J'utiliserai pour faire le voyage du célèbre Rob
vous